مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رفيال
جروس في طهران على وقع قضايا خلافيه
مستمره بين ايران والغرب خلافات تبدا
بالملف النووي ولا تنتهي بالتوتر المتزايد
بين الغرب وايران في ملفات منها اوكرانيا
في الشق النووي تتركز القضايا العالقه في
نقاط رئيسيه التحقيقات حول الاشتباه
بالتخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه نقاء عاليه في
منشاه فوردو والتي تقول الوكاله انها عثرت
فيها على جزيئات اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه
فقط 80% وهذه هي العقبه الاكثر تعقيدا
فالتخصيب وفق النسبه التي تحدثت عنها
الوكاله قريب جدا من درجه النقاء المطلوبه
لصنع الاسلحه النوويه وبينما تقول الوكاله
ان النسبه وصلت الى 83 و7 اعشار في المئه
تصر طهران على لسان رئيس منظمه الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيه محمد اسلامي على ان
التخصيب لم يتجاوز 60%
تتمثل القضيه الثانيه العالقه في وجود
ثلاثه مواقع تقول الوكاله الدوليه انها
تشتبه بوجود انشطه مريبه فيها وهي ترقص
ابد احدى قرى محافظه طهران موقع ابادا في
محافظه فارس
وموقع في منطقه ورمين جنوب شرقي محافظه
طهران ومن القضايا العلقه ايضا تراجع
عمليات التفتيش والرقابه من قبل الوكاله
تراجع اتردا على تداعيات الانسحاب
الامريكي من الاتفاق النووي وحصلت ايران
التفتيش فقط في الحالات المسموح بها بموجب
اتفاق الضمانات وياتي ايقاف ايران تشغيل
كاميرات المراقبه في منشاتها النوويه
المرتبطه بالاتفاق النووي ضمن النقاط
العالقه ايضا اضافه الى ارتفاع المخزون
ايران من اليورانيوم المخصب بالنسبه 60%
وان كانت الخلافات بهذا بين ايران
والوكاله الدوليه فلماذا زار جروس سي
طهران تمت اجابه محتمله ضمن سيناريو
الزياره ويفترض الاحتمال بحسب دبلوماسيين
ايرانيين ان طهران ترغب في ابداء حسن
النيه قبيل اجتماع مرتقب لمجلس محافظ
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه لتفادي
تحرك المجلس لاصدار قرار جديد ضدها خلال
الاجتماع وفي هذه النقطه قد تتقاطع مصالح
ايران مع رغبات